raketenangriffe auf tel aviv der
nahostkonflikt erlebt die schlimmste
eskalation seit vielen jahren beide
seiten verzeichnen schwere verluste
klimapaket im kabinett eine neuerung
mieter und vermieter sollen sich den co2
preis auf öl und gas fifty-fifty teilen
wann werden kinder geimpft die
impfkommission dämpft die hoffnungen auf
einen raschen termin weil ihr noch
entsprechende studien fehlen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen wie
heute 19 uhr an meiner seite für den
sport norbert lehmann einen schönen
bogen antwort von mir
seit wochen schon spitzt sich der
konflikt zwischen palästinensern und
israelis wieder zu seit vorgestern aber
wird scharf geschossen auf den raketen
hagel aus dem gaza-streifen antwortet
israel mit massiven luftangriffen und
hat nach angaben seiner armee führende
hamas-mitglieder getötet auf
israelischer seite starben heute
mindestens fünf menschen
seit montagabend wurden aus dem
gazastreifen mehr als 1000 geschosse auf
israel abgefeuert besonders auf das
nahegelegene aschkelon aber auch auf die
70 kilometer entfernten küstenstadt tel
aviv die israelische armee flog nach
eigenen angaben die schwersten angriffe
auf den gazastreifen seit jahren
israelische panzer auf dem weg ins
grenzgebiet von gaza noch ist offen ob
eine bodenoffensive
der nächste eskalationsschritt in diesem
konflikt sein wird noch läuft der
erwartete gegenschlag israels auf gaza
stadt nach den raketenangriffen auf tel
aviv mit massiven luftschlägen die armee
verkündet dass sie viele hamas führer
getötet habe darunter den kommandeur von
gaza distrikt der verteidigungsminister
macht keine hoffnung auf ein ende der
kampfhandlungen
unsere streitkräfte schlagen zu bis es
völlige ruhe gibt und zwar auf lange
sicht wenn wir das erreicht haben können
wir über die eskalation reden noch gibt
es kein enddatum die hamas gibt sich
trotz der heftigen zerstörungen und der
vielen toten und verletzten
unbeeindruckt doch erstmals seit beginn
der kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
dass die oberster führer bereitschaft
erkennen den konflikt zu entschärfen
wenn israel weiter eskalieren will
unsere bewegung ist bereit wenn es auch
hören will ist die bewegung auch dazu
bereit
dessen ungeachtet von hamas und
islamischer jihad fast ohne pause ihre
raketen ab meist auf das nahegelegene
aschkelon
auch hier gibt es viele verletzte ein
soldat stirbt als sein auto im
grenzgebiet von einer panzer rakete
getroffen wird
für den abend hatte die hamas einen
erneuten angriff auf tel aviv
angekündigt der fand bisher nicht statt
doch die ruhe über der stadt ist
angespannt frage unsere beiden
korrespondenten in israel und den usa
zuerst michael beverungen in tel aviv
steht jetzt ein neuer krieg um gaza
bevor das wird sich wohl die nächsten
stunden und tagen entscheiden die
vorsichtigen signale der hamas lassen
sich vielleicht so deuten dass sie ihre
propaganda ziele in diesem konflikt
erreicht hat sie hat bewiesen dass sie
jerusalem tel aviv um die ganzen großen
städte in zentrale israel erreichen kann
israel wiederum muss unter beweis
stellen und sicherstellen dass genau das
nicht noch einmal passieren kann
wohin dann die logik der eskalation in
der nächsten zukunft führen wird das
lässt sich momentan nicht voraussagen
johannes hano in new york der un
sicherheitsrat hat heute zu dem konflikt
getagt was ist dabei herausgekommen
china norwegen und tunesien hatten den
entwurf für eine stellungnahme
eingebracht in der beide seiten
aufgerufen worden so deeskalieren und in
der israel ganz konkret aufgefordert
wurde die zwangsräumung die zerstörung
von palästinensischen siedlungen zu
stoppen 14 der 15
sicherheitsratsmitglieder haben dieser
stellung mit zugestimmt die amerikaner
haben blockiert mit der begründung das
sei derzeit nicht wirklich opportun das
würde nicht weiterhelfen
hintergrund dafür ist dass die beiden
regierung bei diesem konflikt auf dem
kalten fuß erwischt worden dass man es
kalt erwischt worden
denn man ist dabei eine neue ost
strategie zu formulieren und man sieht
jetzt den versuch in dieser eskalation
von beiden seiten die usa zu zwingen in
eine richtung sich zu positionieren auf
die israelische oder palästinensische
seite unter will man diesem druck jetzt
nicht nach geht man setzt auf bilaterale
gespräche hat aber grundsätzlich
angekündigt dass man auch hier in den
vereinten nationen zu einer gemeinsamen
lösung kommen will
danke ihnen beiden sehr nach new york
und tel aviv eskalation eskalation im
nahen osten sehen sie ein zdf spezial
direkt nach dieser sendung offenbar im
zusammenhang mit der gewalt im nahen
osten hat es vor sich
hogan in nordrhein-westfalen
antisemitische übergriffe gegeben
der präsident des zentralrats der juden
in deutschland schuster forderte
jüdische einrichtungen besser zu
schützen
ministerpräsident laschet und viele
andere politiker verurteilten die
angriffe
in bonn und münster waren in der nacht
israelische flaggen vor synagogen
verbrannt worden
in bonn wurden auch steine auf den
eingangsbereich des gotteshauses
geworfen
der staatsschutz ermittelt gegen 16
verdächtige
das ziel ist klar wie es erreicht wird
noch nicht
deutschland soll bis 2045 klimaneutral
werden fünf jahre früher als geplant
das kabinett hat das geänderte
klimagesetz mit folgenden wegmarken
beschlossen bis 2030 ist eine
verringerung der treibhausgase im
vergleich zu 1990 um 65 prozent geplant
2040 sollen es sogar 88 prozent seien
erheblich mehr einsparen als bisher
geplant müssen die energieerzeuger mehr
details aus berlin von aigs lansky hoch
mit dem klimaschutz kandieren junge
aktivisten vom kanzleramt die die
politik vor sich her treiben denn auch
das heute neu aufgelegte
klimaschutzgesetz mit verschärften
zielen
reicht ihnen nicht dass die
bundesregierung jetzt so ein neues
gesetz präsentiert ist ein reiner
wahlkampf taktischer move es geht hier
nur um fernziele kurz vorm ende der
legislaturperiode schraubt die koalition
ihre etappenziele hoch nachdem vor knapp
zwei wochen erst das
bundesverfassungsgericht mehr
klimagerechtigkeit für die jüngere
generation angemahnt hatte alle
ministerien sind jetzt klimaschutz
ministerium und das ist eine entwicklung
die sich nicht mehr aufhalten lässt wir
können uns ab jetzt auf die ganz
wesentliche frage konzentrieren nämlich
auf das wie wir haben dafür gesorgt ist
die rahmenbedingungen klar sind
aber wir haben eben auch einen klimapakt
mit verabschiedet der zusätzliche
ausgaben von rund acht milliarden euro
für die nächsten beiden
euro vorsieht ehrgeizige ziele doch wer
trägt die kosten energieerzeuger
industrie und verkehr die
hauptverursacher von co2-emissionen
sollen schneller umsatteln die
wirtschaft fürchtet um ihre
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
die regierung muss jetzt einfach schnell
sagen wie das alles funktionieren soll
ohne ökonomische und soziale
verwerfungen mit welchen maßnahmen die
groko die neu gesteckten ziele erreichen
will bleibt offen
die grünen fordern ein schneller ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien
ein ausstieg aus der kohle bis 2030 ein
ausbau von bus und bahn
ein schneller ausstieg aus dem
verbrennungsmotor bis zum jahr 2030 und
ein co2 preis der angemessen ist auch
für verbraucher wird es teurer immerhin
den co2 preis auf heizkosten sollen sich
laut kabinett mieter und vermieter
künftig teil
jetzt also eine fifty fifty regelung für
vermieter und mieter beim thema
heizkosten wie carmen dieser kompromiss
zustande theo das zauberwort lautet ganz
schlicht bundestagswahl
das verfassungsgericht hat sind zwar vor
kurzem schon die weichen richtung
weitergehender klimabeschlüsse gestellt
aber die regierung hätte bis ende
nächsten jahres zeit gehabt für die
umsetzung des jetzt nur zwei wochen nach
dem urteil ein gesetz samt klimapakt
vorliegt das ist eindeutig den näher
rückenden wahltermins geschuldet die
parteien der großen koalition wollten
offensichtlich nicht mit dieser offenen
klima flanke in den wahlkampf ziehen
insbesondere nicht gegen die grüne
konkurrenz und diese massive
beschleunigung hat dann zu dem
überraschenden ergebnis geführt die
union wollte eine reduzierung der eeg
umlage zur entlastung der
stromintensiven industrie und als
gegenleistung bekommen die spd dann die
50 50 meter vermieter regelung bei den
kosten des co2 preis also ein
klassischer politischer kuhhandel mit
namen klimapakt vielen dank für die
einordnung theo koll in berlin jetzt zum
thema corona die welt habe beim ausbruch
der infektionswelle zu langsam reagiert
zu diesem fazit kommt eine unabhängige
kommission die auf mögliche fehler der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und
versuchen sollte nach den ersten
meldungen aus china hätten die bh und
zahlreiche regierungen anfang 2020 zu
viel zeit verloren
erst als die weltgesundheitsorganisation
im märz 2020 von einer pandemie sprach
seien die länder tatsächlich alarmiert
gewesen so die kommission
in deutschland hat jetzt ein drittel der
bevölkerung mindestens eine impfung
gegen korona bekommen kinder sind da
noch außen vor
bisher ist in der eu kein impfstoff für
sie zugelassen allerdings könnte das
mittel von biontech weise schon bald ab
12 freigegeben werden
noch vor ende der sommerferien sollen
alle zwölf bis 18 jährigen ein
impfangebot bekommen sagt
gesundheitsminister sparen experten
halten das inzwischen für unrealistisch
tobias häfner fasst zusammen eine
impfung mit biontech pfizer schon ab 12
jahre kein problem mehr zwischen new
york und kalifornien
die usa haben daten ausgewertet und
grünes licht gegeben
bei uns könnte es wohl bis zum ende der
sommerferien angebote geben meint
gesundheitsminister sparen unrealistisch
halten experten dagegen in meinen augen
wird die politik da etwas zu vorschnell
sein
wir können diese versprechen so erst mal
nicht ein halb wir werden auch nicht
kinder impfen wenn es noch keine
zulassung für den impfstoff gibt und
auch in der regel nicht wenn es keine
stiko impfen er stiko empfehlung gibt
und die impfkommission betont dass man
nicht jede nebenwirkung gleich erkennt
da ist es halt vor allem was die
sicherheit angeht sehr wichtig dass wir
genügend nachbeobachtungszeit haben in
den studien und die in den daten die mir
bis jetzt bekannt sind geht halt über
zwei monate nach der impfung und das
würde ich mir wünschen dass das ein
bisschen länger wäre so oder so für den
sommerurlaub kommen kinderimpfungen zu
spät
die bundesregierung setzt auf eine
andere lösung neue regeln für die
ungeimpften heimkehrer nur wer aus
gebieten mit vielen virus mutationen
einreist kommt selbst mit impfung in
zukunft keinesfalls um 14 tage
quarantäne herum
bei hochrisiko gebieten verkürzt sie
sich ungeimpft aber mit antigen oder pcr
test auf fünf tage viele familien ziele
sind nur noch risikogebiete von dort
erfordert die einreise mit test gar
keine quarantäne mehr was insbesondere
auch etwas manche eltern die mit kindern
reisen wollen wo die eltern
möglicherweise schon geimpft sind dann
für die kunde auch eine lösung ist dann
durch testen die quarantäne entsprechend
zu verkürzen die neuen urlauber regeln
gelten ab morgen milliardenschwere
hilfsprogramme gleichzeitig wegbrechende
steuereinnahmen die pandemie hat tiefe
spuren in den staatskassen hinterlassen
und weil die dritte welle erst langsam
abflaut sind die geschätzten
steuereinnahmen für dieses jahr nach
unten korrigiert worden
andreas cüppers eine gute und eine
schlechte nachricht hat der
finanzminister dabei es wird kurzfristig
noch weniger als gedacht aber
mittelfristig ein bisschen mehr für olaf
scholz ist klar
die gute nachricht zuerst sind auf kurs
und es geht auch wieder aufwärts
die hilfs politik wirkt viele firmen und
betriebe machen wieder gute geschäfte
das macht sich in ihren bilanzen
bemerkbar
und es macht sich auch bei den steuern
dabei muss der bund in diesem jahr mit
3,2 milliarden euro weniger auskommen
als geplant und nimmt erst ab 2024 mehr
ein als im herbst gedacht wer auch immer
nach corona regiert wird entscheiden
müssen sparen oder steuern erhöhen oder
schulden machen vor allem eine zahl
wackelt diese schwarze null ist ausdruck
einer ideologie die sich überlebt hat
und ich finde sie sollte abgeschafft
werden und auch die schuldenbremse
gehört aus dem grundgesetz gestrichen
olaf scholz versucht sein bild als
oberster sparkommissar zu korrigieren
und kündigt an wirtschaftshilfen und
kurzarbeitergeld bis jahresende zu
verlängern
wer kritik übt fliegt raus
das war eine konstante in vier jahren
amtszeit des ehemaligen us-präsidenten
trump und funktioniert offenbar immer
noch weil sie anhaltend kritik an trump
übt wurde liz cheney aus der
fraktionsführung der republikaner im
abgeordnetenhaus geworfen
katrin eigendorf mit einzelheiten eine
richtungsweisende entscheidungen die in
rekordzeit getroffen wurde
so berichten amerikanische medien donald
trumps wichtigste kritikerin liz cheney
bislang fraktionsführerin der
republikaner im abgeordnetenhaus ist
ihres amtes enthoben kaltgestellt damit
stellt sich die partei klar hinter
donald trump kritik an seiner politik
unerwünscht das ist die botschaft über
seine eigene website die er per e-mail
verschickt kommentiert trump die
entscheidung liz cheney ist ein bitterer
und schrecklicher mensch ich habe sie
gestern gesehen und realisiert wie
schlecht sie für die republikanische
partei ist als lupenreine konservative
hat sich liz cheney tochter des
ehemaligen vizepräsidenten dick cheney
einen namen gemacht sie tritt ein für
die alten werte der partei wir müssen
weitermachen und unsere politik auf die
wahrheit gründen wir können nicht
gleichzeitig für die große lüge
und für die verfassung einstehen trumps
rolle im sturm auf das kapitol das
festhalten an der lüge von der
gestohlenen wahl das mache ihn zu einer
gefahr für die demokratie
ich werde alles tun um dafür zu sorgen
dass der ehemalige präsident nicht mehr
in die nähe des oval office gelangt eine
kampfansage die in der partei keine
mehrheit hat donald trump kann diesen
tag als sieg für seine politik verbuchen
die österreichische justiz ermittelt
gegen bundeskanzler kurz wegen einer
möglichen falschaussage im ibiza
untersuchungsausschuss kurz hatte im
ausschuss bestritten dass es politische
absprachen gab als der chef posten bei
einer staatsholding an einen vertrauten
ging allerdings sollen chatprotokolle
das gegenteil beweisen kurz bestreitet
die vorwürfe
in baden württemberg hat der neue
landtag ministerpräsident kretschmann
von den grünen wieder gewählt der 72
jährige erhielt 95 stimmen das sind fünf
weniger als die neu aufgelegte koalition
von grünen und cdu sitze hat kretschmann
sieht es als erste aufgabe der regierung
an die folgen der korona krise für
kinder und jugendliche abzufedern und
nun zur führungskrise im deutschen
fussball wunsch da sind ja jetzt
wichtige personelle entscheidungen dafür
ja allerdings gestern abend hat
präsident fritz keller im dfb präsidium
seinen rücktritt angekündigt er hat er
ja sein vize rainer koch mit einem nazi
richter verglichen nach einer
interimslösung soll die dfb-spitze
anfang nächsten jahres komplett neu
aufgestellt werden
in der präsidiumssitzung hatten die
mitglieder den dfb präsident und auch
den hauptamtlichen generalsekretär
crusius davon überzeugt dass beide ihre
ämter aufgeben müssen präsident fritz
keller hat aus eigener freier
entscheidung in verantwortung des amtes
als präsident seine grundsätzliche
bereitschaft erklärt nach abschluss der
verhandlung vor dem dfb-sportgericht ab
kommenden montag sein amt zur verfügung
zu stellen und vizepräsident koch wurde
offenbar auch dazu bewegt nicht mehr zu
kandidieren
er übernehme nur noch einmal als
interimspräsident und danach seine
mitwirkung als haftender vorstand des
dfb beendet der verband muss alle
spitzenämter neu besetzen
morgen haben in berlin das dfb
pokalfinale leipzig gegen dortmund für
rb wäre es der erste große titel
gewinnen
in der noch jungen vereinsgeschichte der
bvb hatte zuletzt 2017 im pokal geworden
und wieder werden keine zuschauer beim
pokalfinale im stadion sein für julian
nagelsmann wäre ein erfolg mit leipzig
ein schöner abschied vor dem wechsel zu
den bayern
für bvb coach den telegate der einsatz
von erling holland dortmund norwegische
torjäger attraktion nach längerer
verletzung gerade recht wir haben ihn
mitgenommen und wir sind dann halt auch
morgen noch mal auf dem platz und wir
werden einfach gucken wie sich das ganze
entwickelt 3 2 gewannen dortmund gegen
leipzig vor ein paar tagen der
bundesliga von der spannung her war es
vielversprechend
manchester city ist zum siebten mal
englischer meister
das team von pep guardiola und
nationalspieler ilkay gündogan ist drei
spiele vor saisonende nicht mehr von der
spitze zu verdrängen
nachdem stadt rivale manchester united
gestern gegen leicester verloren hatte
beim atp tennis turnier in rom ist jan
lennard struff ausgeschieden
alexander zverev dagegen ist weiter der
hamburger oben im bild gewann sein
auftaktmatch gegen den bolivianer modell
yen deutlich mit 6 2 6 2 und steht im
achtelfinale
dort trifft er dann auf den japaner kei
nishikori und angelique kerber das
angelique kerber das gerade auch
geschafft ins achtelfinale
gut danke norbert und wir haben noch
einen rückblick in eigener sache
heute vor genau 50 jahren präsentierte
wiebke bruns als erste frau in der
bundesrepublik die heute nachrichten im
zdf
und dass das für viele eine sensation
war verstand sie selbst am wenigsten
[Musik]
und diese auffassung hat sich dann ja
auch durchgesetzt
ein großes vorbild und wir haben noch
zum schluss die lottozahlen
sie lauten 12 18 34 42 44 und die
superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 im osten
deutschlands regnet es morgen sehr mehr
dazu gleich beim wetter von westen terry
das war es von uns vielen dank für ihr
interesse das heute journal mit claus
kleber heute erst gegen 10
wir sind dann morgen wieder hier um sie
einen schönen abend jetzt für sie hd
und hier geht es weiter mit dem spezial
zur nahost krise
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter dieses hoch hier
lässt den tiefs keine chance sie müssen
von süd nach nord wandern bringen ganz
viel feuchtigkeit aus dem süden mit
dadurch entwickeln sich viele wolken
schauer und hier im rot auch gewitter
das waren die vergangenen 24 stunden
aber dieser wolken blog hier
der bleibt uns noch erhalten zum
beispiel in der kommenden nacht im osten
deutschlands regnet es kräftig auch
länger andauernd blitz und donner ist
auch dabei und auch im südosten wird es
ziemlich nass im westen lockert es auf
die tiefsten temperaturen mit vier grad
in der eifel und zwölf grad ganz im
osten deutschlands und morgen bleibt es
weiterhin dicht bewölkt im osten regnet
es immer noch kräftig wieder mit
gewittern die bilden sich auch im westen
westlich des rheins wiederum zeigt sich
die sonne mit höchsten temperaturen von
bis zu 20 grad dort und 10 grad im
vogtland die kommenden tage sind
weiterhin durchwachsen am freitag vor
allem nach norden in den süden lockert
es mal auf 12 bis 18 grad aber die
schauer und gewitter setzten sich in den
darauffolgenden tagen weiter fort 12 bis
19 grad die höchsten werte damit ein
schöner abend